hello rejects it's Greg Pierce
I just realized your dream I sure can do
this it's Christmas time it's cold
outside
so I'm in my you know bumming it out
outfits my time my long-sleeve raggedy
shirt no I like it looks like you just
got back from like chopping wood
drinking maple syrup boy Jordan hey I
got you a gazelle
what's your gazelle chopped down some
wood for ya
all right John we're going to watch the
trailer there's a show coming out of FX
called taboo taboo produced by Risley a
pic of that guy from the black guy oh no
no more jokes no more jokes the rest of
this video produced by Ridley produced
by Ridley Scott starring Thomas Hardy I
think it's an FX miniseries because I
doubt Tom Hardy would just be like [ __ ]
it I'll do an FX show for the rest of my
succeed okay there's like four 30-second
promos or I think one of them is 1
minute long so we're looking at like a
full two minutes yeah two and a half
minutes shotgun Moran you know we'll
decide based off feeling when we'll stop
and talk about it or if we you know just
want to move on to the next one let's
see we're gonna start with the first one
taboo the prestige Steve
Oh
foolish thing for dead in half advance
because I left
No
all right so first impressions versus
price job okay you know we're a movie
talk show so just a little bit okay
stylistically very cool I'm a big fan of
American Horror Story American horror
stories on FX
I see similarities a lot in style
already from like certain framing and
visual like violence that were being
presented here like if American Horror
Story took place in like one of those
BBC period yeah like in Jonathan strange
like if that's where yeah an American
Horror Story is taking place yeah you
know I just seen Tom Hardy in it and
something like this is really cool Tom
Hardy is not shy of any kind of genre or
project but this looks to have a horror
element in there that is like oh yeah
Tom Hardy like some horror themed kind
of show yeah that sounds pretty cool
alright that's only 30 seconds let's
move on to the next one he look like
Charlie Hunnam in this doesn't he
yeah looks a little bit Jim and Charlie
hunter could play brothers that two
convoys Oh plunder
nice I know the evil that you do because
I was once part of it
ah I really want to see this you're like
really bad
yeah it looks healthy as hell is it's
awesome it looks like Pope I love period
pieces - and I love period 11th period
pieces and shows where you really get a
sense of the time that they're in that
grimy cockney accent just just doesn't
yeah yeah you know four months an extra
was an IMDB plot of this a man who has
been at the ends of the earth that comes
back irrevocably changed believe long
dead he returns to London from Africa
okay yeah Kirby did see some of that
Africa moment in there in 1814 and
heroin is left of his father's shipping
Empire but when this legacy is revealed
to be a poison chalice with enemies in
every dark corner James must navigate
complex territories to avoid his own
death sentence ooh it's like a game of
Thrones if you know what I mean it's not
like the show game with her but it's a
game of authority a game of power we're
dealing with here I love especially a
show when the show is a lot about the
rise to power really corrupt power -
yeah yeah that's always very intriguing
to me so I want to be a criminal
wondering if these these pros are gonna
get more stories now cuz like the first
two at least had been very like stuff
look it's all yeah look at how cool our
style is well this next one thirty
seconds called dear James Oh
since you came back time itself has
stopped eyes I didn't know I had
Wow darkness that you cannot conceive
tensions guarding James going to be
wearing most civilized wine would have
intentions regarding him
John to find the word taboo taboo is
like something that's that's sort of
widely viewed as uh you know forbidden
or faux pas I think that really
describes this overseeing so yeah
because this looks evil as funny this
does not look Pleasant whatsoever
I love the production design of
everything I feel like this trailer too
gave us even more into like this the
lustful sexual side of the world and
that's I mean like this is perfect for
FX to do something like this especially
when I think of like American Horror
Story which is so filled with lust and
violence and Garner there seems to be
like ghostly things happening here like
this doesn't seem like it's just human
characters I feel like there is like
some supernatural element at play here
of this one shot here where he's like
underwater Tom Hardy looks like a ghost
is strangling him
yeah something and then like you get
these other shots of like people and
like or just super pale or like to have
like some white makeup all over them
this chick is like being like she's tied
out like this and her legs are spread
and there's candles around her like I
really this will deal with like
witchcraft in some way oh yeah I mean
this seems like this is the I married or
what you know like all taboo it seems
like a perfect title like you said it
seems like it's all gonna be sort of
dark uncomfortable stigmatic ge is
pneumatic you and the word and M of the
words you use I don't know if that's
actually a real word no there's now some
of these shots look like oil pit feels
like a haunting show yeah like if you if
I was to hear like a British haunting
this has I kind of that foggy look about
it totally telling the shadows and
everything the production I mean who's
this is FX millionaire production
designers intent there we go there's a
minute trailer called little men who
hope it's about midgets little people
little man is a man aren't you
dwarf just and judge-made this is like
an african Iitate just like today is
futile and a ghost appeared a side wall
for dead in Africa James because I like
knives
I dunno the evil that you do because I
was once part of it this man is merely a
London monkey
I would just hear him thank you
you know what people might not agree me
saying this but this sort of feels like
this is American Horror Story meets Game
of Thrones they're kind of I get around
ready coming from with with that you
know 19 like we got this Tom Hardy Karen
Aaron century we got this Tom Hardy
character with like who's this character
everyone's like he should be dead and
understand Jim dead I wouldn't be
surprised if he did die and he came back
from the dead and that's his character
or if he is just a ghost or something
for or maybe he has some kind of weird
you know supernatural power to him so
yeah or supernatural affliction while he
is the central character where a lot of
this plot is revolving around it does
seem like we're gonna get a wide variety
of other characters in this political
power at this time or it seems like a
Wars gonna break out and that's why I
get like an American Horror Story in
terms of its violence its lust that kind
of sinister approach political power at
war here you know I don't credit these
only to American Horror Story like I get
it has like that kind of the horror II
bits feel kind of American Horror Story
but this is stuff that's popular across
the board I mean a total it's it's dark
and airy and it's period and it's high
production value and it's intrigue not
that this is gonna be you know it's the
politics of whatever that situation is
yeah but he's like Tom are you seriously
he's returning back home to like take
control yeah yeah take rein of all this
stuff and it seems like he's out to kill
people because they keep showing that
lunch on all the trends on that one shop
where he has something in his hand he's
got like the blood filling on his
forehead yeah wondering like who is it
that he killed it was at a past moment
as I like when he returns homes that
like is that the oh [ __ ] moment at the
end of episode one yeah I mean I it
seems like we're probably gonna get to
know all these care now you had a lot of
curiosity I saw a lot of Jonathan
strange recently I still got to finish
that series but I get that kind of vibe
from this just with a darker sort of
horrific edge na that means there's some
good cast and there's something
character actors and stuff Jonathan
Pryce Jonathan Pryce smart never dies
parts of the Caribbean best let's go to
that yeah runs one right after
the price Street yeah this looks like a
whole other level of TV this is cool
hour I wonder furtively Scott directed
any episodes I wouldn't be surprised
that'd be pretty cool if you like
directed the pilot or something yeah
make me a million times more intrigued
to watch it I get excited when like a
big film director directs like a pilot
or something like when salad I'm gonna
have to go over it did preacher and
Scorsese did Boardwalk Empire
I get really enthused about checking
stuff up now is a cool time for TV in
that regard because you're seeing you
know cooler and cooler and more
interesting stuff you know getting a
platform now and then you know even if
you've liked filmmakers like being on TV
isn't as weird as it used to be it's
true you know this haunting dread looks
very appealing I can't wait do it let's
do it to do all right
rejects if you're new to the channel
subscribe today become a reject John is
reasons to Jerry on his Twitter and
Instagram and he is a social media
manager of Facebook's bloom house and
Facebook's real rejects page and shout
out a Tom Hardy when he is hard I read a
chord about him like talking about how
he wants you know experimented with men
hmm because he wasn't he's an artist
didn't realize it wasn't for him and I
found myself on a similar path just
because he had that quote I believe that
about you any better